>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Marie Arana: This first
program which is very,
very dear to my heart is brought
to you by the Centro Primo Levi
in New York, a very important
center that does great,
great work on behalf of Primo Levi,
and I how you will download
the brochure which they offer,
and Alessandro Cassin will tell
you a little bit more about that,
their great work on Primo Levi.
And of course the United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum,
we are very, very lucky
to have Michael Abramowitz
who is the director of the
committee on conscious--
on conscience at the museum
with us today to moderate.
We have the translator of Primo
Levi's works, Ann Goldstein,
and her wonderful colleague from
The New Yorker, Adam Gopnik.
You are going to enjoy this
very, very much, I promise you.
And we are starting, kicking off
just to hear directly very important
to do so, the voice
of Primo Levi himself.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> [Background Music] Our roots were
Piedmont in Turin, not enormous,
but deep, extensive and
fantastically intertwined.
My ancestors were never
much loved or much hated.
Nevertheless, a wall of
suspicion of undefined hostility
and mockery must have kept
them substantially separated
from the rest of the population.
[ Music ]
There are so-called inert
gases in the air we breathe.
They bare curious Greek
names of erudite derivation
which mean the new, the hidden,
the inactive and the alien.
The little I know about my
ancestors presents many similarities
to these gases.
Not all of them were materially
inert for that was not granted then.
But there is no doubt that they
were inert in their inner spirits,
inclined to disinterested
speculation.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Music ]
None of us alien or Jew had
yet the idea of one must
and could resist fascism.
Our resistance at the
time was passive.
Fascism did not have opponents.
Fascist censorship master stroke
kept us shut off from the world
in a white anesthetized limbo.
My Christian classmates
were civil people
but I could feel them withdraw.
Every look exchanged between us
was accompanied by a miniscule
but perceptible flash of
mistrust and suspicion.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Music ]
We proclaimed ourselves
enemies of fascism
but actually fascism
had had its effect on us
as in almost all the
talents alienated us,
made us superficial,
passive and cynical.
Out of the shadows came in
whom fascism had not crushed.
They talked to us about
[inaudible] who were they?
[ Music ]
[ Foreign Language ]
Somebody betrayed us.
And on the dawn of December 13,
1943, we woke surrounded by fascist.
During those days, when I was
waiting fairly courageously
for death, I harbored a
piercing desire for everything,
for all imaginable human experience,
and I curse my proceeding life
which it seemed to me I had taken
little and poor advantage of.
I felt I'm slipping
through my fingers.
[ Music ]
Night came and it was such a night
when you got human eyes would
not witness it and survive.
Everyone felt this.
Not one of the guards, either
Italian or German had the courage
to come and see what men do
when they know they have to die.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Abramowitz:
So welcome everybody.
My name is Michael Abramowitz.
I'm the director of
the Levine Institute
for Holocaust education
at the Holocaust Museum.
It's really a thrill for me to be
here with a great group of panelist.
Why are we here today?
We're here in tribute to Primo
Levi, the Italian scientist
and Auschwitz survivor who became
an exemplary voice of conscious,
really one of the first to bring to
a wider audience the reality of life
within the logger, as he
termed the death camps.
Levi was an incredibly complex man,
a type of intellectual character
that we rarely encounter today.
Intensely literate in literary, his
curiosity equally aroused by science
and the natural world as by behavior
and the nature of good and evil.
He wrote short stories,
science fiction, poetry.
He edited dramatic
versions of his work
for theatrical productions
on stage and radio.
And he began by writing
what he called "plain
or disguised autobiography", about
his experiences in Auschwitz.
And now, thanks to the prodigious
efforts of one of our panelist,
Ann Goldstein of the New Yorker,
we have the complete works
of Primo Levi, which is the
occasion for this discussion.
It is a collection
of every known work
that Primo Levi wrote now
translated into English.
It includes the most
well-known words,
as well as Levi's private
collection of writings.
In total, the collection spans
three volumes and 3000 pages.
How many times did you read it, Ann?
>> Ann Goldstein: Quite a number.
But I just want to insert that
I was not the only translator.
This was a great team.
>> Michael Abramowitz: We--
Yes, we're going to get to that.
And there are roughly 3000 pages,
200 essays, columns, forwards,
inscription reviews,
works of fiction, poems,
and each have their articles.
Tracing is evolution
from a narrative writer
to a more analytical writer
at the end of his life.
So we're going to enjoined in
conversation by Ann's colleague
at the New Yorker, Adam Gopnik.
Welcome, Adam.
And I'd like to about translation
but I first would like to start
with Primo Livo himself, the man,
which is why we're here, and like,
both of you just take a crack at
why he's such a significant figure
in the 20th century literature not
just as a holocaust writer but also
as someone who spoke to
larger issues in literature.
Anne, why don't you start?
>> Ann Goldstein: Well,
of course my--
I'm a partisan of Primo Levi because
I spent a lot of time with him.
But I think that he does
have this voice of sort of,
of calmness in the midst
of a lot of uncalmness.
I mean he has a very-- in
spite of the terrible things
that he often describes, he's got a
very-- a quiet and, superficially,
I would say dispassionate view of
that-- of what he's talking about.
Underneath it, I think there's a lot
of passion, actually, that you find.
But I think that's one
of the things that he--
that he's so amazingly does,
and that-- that's rare I think.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Adam?
>> Adam Gopnic: Yeah.
I agree entirely with Ann.
But what-- the way I
would think about it is
that Levi was a scientist, and
that was core to what he did.
Of all of his books, my
favorite is "The Periodic Table".
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: Which
is an attempt to sort
of rewrite his personal
history in terms
of the elements of
the periodic table.
And there's something, I think,
that combination of a scientist,
and this isn't exactly the right
word, the dispassionate survey
of experience combined with
his, for lack of a better word,
he's an old-fashioned one,
his humanity at all times,
and the way those two things
were always intentioned.
He's witnessed, as a humanist
and his dry, often ironic,
usually mordant, always
dispassionate voice
as a scientific observer of human
experience and human quality.
I think it's the way those two
things are constantly intention
on his work that makes him not
just a witness but a great author.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Right.
So this project, Ann, I think it
took maybe 10 years to put together.
>> Ann Goldstein: Maybe more.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Maybe more?
But can you--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yes.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Can you tell
us a little bit about the origins
of the project and both how
the project came together
but also what kind of
attracted you to Primo Levi.
You've translated many
other writers--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Michael Abramowitz: -- but
what attracted you to Primo Levi?
>> Ann Goldstein: Well,
the project began with--
it was the idea of Robert
Weil, an editor at Norton--
or what is now Liveright,
a part of Norton.
And he had put together a volume of
the collected works of Isaac Babel.
And he had been-- he had loved
Primo Levi for many years.
I mean been-- felt Primo
Levi was great and compelling
and important writer, and he got the
idea that he would the same thing
for Primo Levi, not realizing
that it was a rather
different-sized task.
Primo Levi's work has been
translated into English
in a very sort of haphazard fashion.
His important books had
all been translated.
This is a man, the truth
of the periodic table.
But a lot of his-- he wrote
a lot of short stories,
as you mentioned, and essays.
And those had been published
in English in, as I say,
sort of haphazard piecemeal fashion
in different collections, you know,
three from this book, four from this
book put together into a volume.
And they were not done in the
way that Levi had wanted to.
So when Bob Weil started, when he--
he had this idea, then he asked me
if I would be interested in
come joining him in this idea,
we realized that this was the case.
We hadn't really realized it,
so that it was a much bigger job
to collect-- to put the-- all the
books back in their original format.
And then we saw that some things--
there were things that hadn't
been translated, there were a lot
of essays and stories that
haven't even been collected at all.
So then we decided to do
this big project which was
to retranslate everything, put
it in the order in which it had--
in the-- in chronologic order.
We put all the books together the
way they were originally published
following the Italian
collected works.
So that's what happened.
But Bob first spent about five
years getting the English rights
which were scattered all over the
place in many different places.
So that took some time.
And then I joined in 2004.
And then we spent 11
years, I would say.
>> Michael Abramowitz: But the--
>> Ann Goldstein: And then--
>> Michael Abramowitz:
But the individual books,
they can't be sold
separately, you have to--
>> Ann Goldstein: No, you
have to buy the whole package.
But it's a deal.
>> Adam Gopnic: It's a fabulous
bargain, everybody is doing it.
And if I may just quickly say,
because he's not my editor,
so I have no commercial
allegiance to him.
Bob Weil is one of those rare people
who's left, in American publishing,
who actually has this
passionate connection.
>> Ann Goldstein: Two books.
>> Adam Gopnic: Two books.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Right.
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: And it's not
the type that's supposed to--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: --
survive, but he does
and he feels hugely passionate--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: -- about
making literature live.
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: So--
>> Ann Goldstein: And then
I would just say that--
so when we realize
the scope of the--
of this as a translation project,
we needed a few more translators,
one of whom is here
today, Michael Moore.
And-- So there were, I always
forget the exact number,
but there were I think 10
or 11 translators plus me.
So it was a big project.
>> Adam Gopnic: And Anne, is there a
uniform edition of Levi in Italian?
>> Ann Goldstein: Yes, there is.
There's a two-volume, which I think
is about to be three volumes, right?
>> Michael Abramowitz: So--
I'm going to bring Alessandro--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
No, it's OK.
>> Michael Abramowitz: So Levi is
such as a meticulous,
careful writer.
What were the special challenges
that you faced, or you and team,
shall we say, in bringing from
the Italian to the English?
>> Ann Goldstein: You
know, there's some--
I mean his sentences are complex.
I mean-- I keep doing this.
>> Michael Abramowitz: You're fine.
You're find just--
>> Ann Goldstein: His sentences
are complex, his ideas are complex,
but he is also a very clear writer.
So-- But to make-- to balance that,
to get that into English proper
is sometimes the challenge.
He uses a lot of scientific terms.
Those are always difficult.
He has-- His descriptions are
very-- often very detailed.
And those can be difficult.
So those are some of the challenges,
I mean apart from just the
regular challenges of translation.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Right.
Adam, you've written in
the past about translation.
What is your sense of the project
here in terms of what's impressive
from the point of view of
a translation perspective?
>> Adam Gopnic: Well, I have the
huge advantage of not being able
to read Italian, so I
can opine on the virtues
of this translation
with special authority.
But about a year ago, I guess
it was, I wrote a long piece
about the nature of translation.
So I don't know if anybody saw,
but that's-- it was published in--
first in French and then in English,
a thing called the "Dictionary
of Untranslatables" which was
a kind of huge encyclopedia
of all the terms that could not
be translated from one language
to another, although, in fact,
this book had been very
successfully translated from French
into English using
all of these things.
So-- And in truth, what the point
in the book really was, is that,
there are particular terms in words
and vocabulary in every language
that is ultimately
translatable but delicate
and fragile in transmission.
And I suspect-- the thing that
struck me, right, reading it,
and I know there's no
answer to this question--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: Levi's tone, at
least as I read it in English,
is often dryly ironic
in complicated ways.
That he usually is, and
we just saw it in the--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: -- in the film.
That's his way--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah,
sort of his--
>> Adam Gopnic: -- in
addressing the world.
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: Kind of
caustic understatement.
Is-- And English tends not to
lend itself as easily to that?
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah, that's true.
So, I mean, I think sometimes,
probably, things are more--
are less fine than they might
have been in the original.
But as a translator, you
can only do what you can do.
But we, you know, I
mean, we, you know, I--
the translators I went
back and forth with,
all the translators many times
on their books, I mean, you know,
we discuss a lot of things.
We had the help of the Primo
Levi Center in New York
and the Primo Levi Center in Turin.
So I think that in the end,
of course as a translator,
one of your greatest-- or
should I say nightmares
of second guessing yourself.
But my hope is that
we got to something
that is less-- that
is pretty accurate.
And not-- But not, but
not dry, I mean not--
>> Michael Abramowitz: Literal.
>> Ann Goldstein:-- literal,
not literal, mind you.
Anyway, I didn't really
answer your question but--
>> Adam Gopnic: You
know, that is the answer,
is that there is no rule.
>> Ann Goldstein: There's no rule.
>> Adam Gopnic: There's a--
>> Ann Goldstein: No.
I mean there's that famous Italian
expression "traduttore, traditore",
every translator is a betrayer.
So, what can you do when
you're up against that.
>> Michael Abramowitz: I don't--
We have a limited amount of time.
>> Ann Goldstein: I'm sorry.
>> Michael Abramowitz: I want to
talk a little bit-- No, it's OK.
I would like to talk about
Primo Levi as a writer.
You know, one of the things
that I find interesting is his
"If This Is a Man" was really one
of the first survivor's memoir,
I think, first published in 1947.
And it took another 12 years, I
believe, before it's published
in the 50s in the United States, and
I think it was arguably really not
until the mid-80s,
shortly before his death,
that it really became
recognized especially in America
as this gigantic literary figure.
And I'm really curious, for both of
you, you know, was there a reason
that it took so long for Levi to be
really recognized in the way it had
to do with him as a writer,
it had to do with the holocaust is
a phenomenon and the initial kind
of unwillingness to grapple
with the kind of, you know,
really the horribleness
of the whole episode.
I don't know, Ann, if you
have any thoughts about that.
>> Ann Goldstein: Well, I mean I
think that's one of the reasons
that he wasn't known--
well-known in America anyway.
But the book that made
him famous in America was
"The Periodic Table" was
not the holocaust memoirs.
But, I mean interestingly, the
"If This Is A Man", his first book
which was about his fear in
Auschwitz was originally published
as "Survival In Auschwitz".
>> Adam Gopnic: Absolutely.
>> Ann Goldstein: And at that time,
I mean because people were beginning
to, I think, sort of be interested
in or aware of the holocaust, I
mean, I think right after the war,
nobody want to think
about it in Italy or here.
But then at that-- when it was first
published in English, that was--
"Auschwitz" was a term that
was-- would attract attention,
and then the idea of survival had to
be something positive in America--
>> Adam Gopnic: Right.
>> Ann Goldstein: -- anyway.
>> Adam Gopnic: Yes,
it's an upbeat story--
>> Ann Goldstein: Upbeat
story, right, exactly.
But I don't know, what
do you, you know--
>> Adam Gopnic: Well, you
know, I think is, you know,
and I know study closely, Michael.
One of the fascinating
things about the storiography
of the holocaust is, the long
delay, and people understanding.
It is still startling
thing when you look
at the literature, the
atrocity literature.
That it's literature about
Nazi atrocities after the war,
everything gets kind
of mixed together.
And sort of the most famous film
of the immediate post-war is the
"Dock Out" [assumed
spelling], right,
which was a horrific place
but not distinguished.
Their death camps were not
distinguished clearly at all
from concentrations camps and
from the rest of the lager system.
And so, I think that it
took some clarification.
I think it's not an accident that
"The Periodic Table" is the book
that kind of tipped him
over in a certain way,
exactly because Levi seemed
to be a postmodernist.
He seem to belong with Aborjez
or Cortis [assumed spelling]
or someone like that.
Because the organization of that
book was so highly literary with--
was at such a high level
of artifice that it--
unlike say, Elie Wiesel's
testimony which tended
to have a much more direct, you
could give to eighth grade class
and they would understand
the material.
And Levi-- even in, it seems to me,
in the-- in his Auschwitz memoir,
is writing with a literary
self-consciousness that's quite
remarkable amongst in all of the--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: -- in all of
the literature of survival,
and all of the literature
of the holocaust.
And I think that book
made it more difficult.
But ultimately, when it came-- he
came round again as a writer rather
than as a witness, and I think
that's one of the reasons why his--
he seems to occupy a larger place.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Let--
You know, you actually touched
on something that I am curious
about especially thinking
about ElieWiesel a lot
over the last several months
with his recent death.
You know, he was arguably much
more embraced in the United States
than Primo Levi initially.
And I'm just kind of curious if you
think there is a reason for that.
>> Ann Goldstein: Well, you
sort of touched on it really.
I mean--
>> Adam Gopnic: Yes.
>> Ann Goldstein: --
he's-- you said why.
No. I mean I think he--
it was more direct.
You know, he was sort of more--
a more direct witness, I guess--
>> Michael Abramowitz: Right.
>> Adam Gopnic: And I say this with
no-- without any invidiousness.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Sure.
>> Adam Gopnic: He dramatized
his role as a survivor in a way
that you only have to watch Levi.
He's one of the most beautiful
faces I think in the 20th century
in the combination of
sensitivity and intelligence.
And that's a very different kind of
address that the one that Wiesel,
to his credit and without--
essentially popular address
that Wiesel offered and kind
of popular witness and going around
and being with heads of state
and playing that particular kind
of role, nothing wrong about it,
but it's not the role
Levi chose to play at all.
To my mind, I don't
know if you'd agree, I--
the two best essays in English
about Primo Levi are both
by Clive James [inaudible]
colleague of ours at The New Yorker
who often writes about
Italian literature.
And he talks about Levi I think with
insight and a kind of brilliance
that I recommend to anybody
who's curious about Levi's work.
>> Michael Abramowitz: You know, one
thing I was curious about, I was--
I did not read the all 3000
pages but a couple of books.
But at the, you know, at the end
of "The Drowned and the Saved",
his last published work, Levi had
some very powerful words, I thought.
He said quote-- He
wrote, "It happened once
and it could happen again.
This is at the heart
of what I have to say."
And so, this is the
mid-80s that he's writing.
And he goes on to describe what
he terms as a precursory signs
that are appearing in 1980s, you
know, things he thought, I think,
might be precursors to
maybe not another holocaust
but the mass atrocities perhaps.
He talked about violence,
governmental lawlessness,
intolerance, political fanaticism.
Then he wrote, "We need to sharpen
our sense and distrust the prophets,
the charismatics, the persons
who speak and write fancy words
without the backing
of sound reasons."
It's very--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yell.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
So I'm really kind
of curious whether you think
Levi, from having, you know,
read the totality of works, whether
you saw Auschwitz as an aberration,
something unprecedented,
not to be repeated,
or do you think he was writing
with maybe a more preventative,
you know, warning--
>> Ann Goldstein: No, I--
>> Michael Abramowitz: -- the
world of what could happen?
>> Ann Goldstein: I think he was.
I mean he definitely thought
it could happen again.
I mean that it wasn't--
>> Adam Gopnic: I think that--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: --
that's one of the things.
That's what's moving in his work
and is very much part of his--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: -- his testimony
as an Italian Jew, is that,
it all happens insidiously.
That's one of the things that--
>> Ann Goldstein: Right.
>> Adam Gopnic: --
that occurs, right?
It goes from a kind of O Fish
[assumed spelling] pantomime
of power into something--
into a sinister alliance,
and that every point along away, you
feel that you're protected from it
because it doesn't
affect you directly.
And then finally, it
turns to sending someone
who doesn't need self-identify
as a Jew obviously,
but is not whose primary
identity is not as a Jew
but his primary identity is
as a scientist, and Italian,
a humanist finds himself
in the death camp.
And so, I think that is the
recurrent, in the certain sense,
you might almost say, it seems to
me at least that Levi assumes that,
in a certain sense, fascism is
the default condition of mankind.
That it's always that those
pathogens are always present
and they're always possible.
They're not aberration
that needs to be explained,
they're the permanent
risk that we have
to immunize ourselves
against perpetually.
>> Ann Goldstein: When he
talks about the sense of shame,
for example, that the
survivors felt,
he says one of the reasons is--
for that is that it was men who
made Auschwitz and we were all men.
So I think that he's talking
about the fact, what you--
>> Adam Gopnic: Yeah.
>> Ann Goldstein: -- of
it's always being possible.
>> Michael Abramowitz: You know,
one of the things that Levi wrote
about is what he described
as the gray zone.
You know, this was a scale that
he created to challenge kind
of the oversimplification of kind
of the division of the people there
and to victims, bystanders,
perpetuators.
And he didn't-- he, by
acknowledging, you know,
even though his own moral and
ethical compromises which lead
to collaboration with the Nazis.
And he did not, as I said,
exempt himself from the scale.
And he felt guilty for having
survived and for the advantages
that he received compared to others.
And I'm just kind of curious, as
you look through the entirety,
how much of this kind of
self-criticism and willingness
to kind of look on functionally as
its self is a hallmark of his work?
>> Ann Goldstein: I
think definitely, yeah.
I think he's definitely
would be looking
at himself all the time in a way.
I mean I think he's-- he's
not a-- he doesn't really--
he doesn't let himself
off the hook ever really.
I think he's very-- I mean many
of his works are autobiographical.
And even the ones that aren't have
a little hint of autobiography.
Well, all writers, of course,
are always writing themselves.
But, no. But I mean
he as a particular--
I mean when he's writing about
science, he's writing about many--
in many ways, he's
writing about himself.
Examining-- This isn't
exactly answering your question
but I mean he does--
I think he does--
he is constantly judging
himself in some way.
>> Adam Gopnic: Yeah.
I think Anne is exactly right.
I think one of the things that
drive us to them is that his--
the nature of his kind of moral
inquiry is unsparing about himself.
And I'm talking about
the gray zones.
I think what he has
in mind is, is that,
we don't have the luxury
of simply being victims.
In any extreme human
situation, what you find--
this is a trivial version
of the same thing, right,
relatively trivial version, but it's
something that's make a television
series like "Orange Is The
New Black" so intriguing is
that the unique division of the
imprisoned and the prisoners.
Those who are in prison and
those who are imprisoned breaks
down in the actual reality of it.
And though he has no moral ambiguity
about who's good and who's bad,
nonetheless, human behavior is
complex and not melodramatic.
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Adam Gopnic: He's the
least melodramatic poet
of the most melodramatic
possible situations, and that's,
I think, part of what makes him--
>> Alessandro Cassin: Absolutely.
I think that Adam just explained
very well one of touched on,
one of the major differences
between him and Elie Wiesel in terms
of Elie Wiesel identifying with
victim and Levi refusing this role
of a victim or complicating
it at least.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Forgive,
I just introduced-- I was--
a little bit later but
you're Alessandro Cassin
from the Primo Levi Center.
No, please.
Do you want to add anything else--
>> Alessandro Cassin: No, no.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
-- to the conversation?
OK. I'm going to give you a
chance before we go to questions.
And you-- the audience should
be thinking of questions.
I think we have a few
more minutes of discussion
and then we'll open it up.
Just to stay on this idea
of the self-criticism,
do you think that Levi
thought of writing it all
as a therapeutic thing for himself
or is that maybe a little bit of--
>> Ann Goldstein: Little modern--
>> Michael Abramowitz:
Little modernist.
>> Ann Goldstein: Little modern.
I don't know.
I mean I don't think so.
I mean he wrote because
he wanted to--
he had something that
he wanted to say.
I mean originally he wanted to-- he
felt that it was crucial to report
on what he had seen at Auschwitz.
And I think that was
the origin, really.
I mean he talks about the-- I
mean he talks a lot about writing
and about words, about the
importance of language,
and I think all those things are
really why he wanted, why he wrote.
I don't think it was-- I
don't think he thought of it
as therapeutic necessarily--
>> Michael Abramowitz: Right.
>> Ann Goldstein: -- at all.
>> Michael Abramowitz: You
know, one of the things
that is also interesting to me
about Levi is he does not
absolve the German people even
after the holocaust has
ended, and not just the Nazis
but the entire German population.
Again quoting from the-- at the
end of "The Drowned and the Saved".
You know, "From the beginning,
out of mental laziness,
near-sighted calculations,
stupidity and national pride.
They accepted the fancy
words of 'Corporal Hitler'.
Followed him as long
as he was blessed
by faith and a lack [inaudible].
We're devastated by this downfall,
ravaged by grief, misery and remorse
and rehabilitated a few years later
but unprincipled political
gamesmanship."
So he wasn't really
buying the idea, I think,
that Germany had been rehabilitated.
>> Adam Gopnic: I think that
the catastrophe what we now call
the holocaust--
>> Michael Abramowitz: Right.
>> Adam Gopnic: -- of the Second
World War more broadly, it was,
for him, a catastrophe
of European civilization.
It wasn't just the
Germans were responsible,
though obviously they were.
It was that all of
European civilization
and it's most basic premises,
that's at least how I read them,
had been not only undermined
but in certain-- well, he says--
he said it in what we were
watching a moment ago.
Europe, an idea of Europe, an
idea of European civilization came
to an end at Auschwitz,
and how do we construct it,
how to rebuild it after that.
That's one of the things
that makes him so powerful,
and it's one of the things--
again, this is one of the themes
that I know Clive James
for instance takes up,
that makes his own
personal trajectory,
his own biography compelling
and significant.
You know, did he take his own life.
That's a question that means a
great deal to us because it touches
on our sense of is there any
expiation, is there any recompense
in bearing witness even as he do.
And I think it's one of the big
questions that his work presents.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
Well, before we--
before I turn it over to Allesandro,
I did want to ask, as I've said,
there's many books, there's
dozens of articles in a year.
I just be curious from Ann,
what are some of the [inaudible]
in here that-- I mean obviously
we know the most famous
of the Levi works but, you know,
for a person just dipping into this,
what are the two or three
kind of things that kind
of surprised you in there.
>> Ann Goldstein: Well, there's
a collection of stories called
"Lilith" which has some great
stories, wonderful stories in it.
And then the other book that I
think is also really interesting is
"Other People's Trades"
which is a lot of essay
which on a huge range of topics.
So those-- I mean there's a
lot in there to keep you busy.
And I think the science fiction
stories also are really interesting,
some better than others but
they're very-- they're good.
You don't expect them,
I think, from Levi.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
Is the later Levi--
How much different is
he than the earlier Levi
or is there a consistency
through those--
>> Ann Goldstein: I think there's--
>> Michael Abramowitz: -- 40 years?
>> Ann Goldstein: So I
think they're pretty--
there's a pretty solid consistency.
I mean maybe his writing
becomes more writerly [phonetic]
in a way but it's all--
>> Michael Abramowitz:
The tone seems very--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah, exactly.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
The voice seems to be--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah, it seems
very-- Yeah, I think it's the same.
>> Michael Abramowitz: OK.
So we're-- I'm grateful
to have Alessandro
from the Primo Levi
Center, and maybe--
>> Alessandro Cassin: Thank you.
>> Michael Abramowitz: -- you
might want to say a few words
about Primo Levi and this book--
>> Alessandro Cassin:
Yes, thank you.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
-- conversation.
>> Alessandro Cassin: Absolutely.
I'd like to thank, first of all,
The Library of Congress, [inaudible]
and the speakers and the moderator
for a very stimulating discussion.
I'd like to spend just a few
words, really the main mission
of Primo Levi which is to
usher the humanistic legacy
of Primo Levi into the future.
By legacy, I mean the fundamental
ethical questions raised by his work
and his far-reaching
analysis of human nature.
I'll get back to this in a minute.
You know, during the past few
months, as all of you know,
many critics and writers have
expressed themselves so eloquently
and the cultural importance
of Liveright's complete
works of Primo Levi.
For me, with an additional
personal important dimension to this
as my father Orion Press
published the first edition
"If This Is A Man"
in English in 1959.
And so, for me, this event is also
a sort of a closing of a circle.
I'd like-- Anne Goldstein can attest
to the challenging-- challenges--
the many challenges and complexities
of translating Primo Levi.
I think what's equally
challenging is to understand the way
that Primo Levi became such as
a towering public intellectual,
really a moral compass for post-war
Italy and for our present world.
In this edition, this
edition contributes to this
by including a number
of articles and essays
in which Primo Levi
directly addresses
and observes the world
that he lived in.
I think by doing this, he
provides us a lens through which,
to better understand and analyze
the ambitions and pitfalls
of modern societies in general.
Way beyond the holocaust,
this is really what he does.
Primo Levi was a man
of the 20th century.
His-- The arch of his life really
spans from the end of World War I
to the years immediately leading
to the fall of the Berlin Wall.
Endlessly curious and inquisitive,
Levi had the rare gift
of a true observer.
I think the depth of his vision made
him one of the great commentators
of our times, but back
to his legacy.
When I talk about the
legacy of his work,
I'm referring to his lucid
observations of the human conditions
as seen in some of the most
extreme imaginable circumstances.
And the cleared eye analysis of
a relationship of the powerful
with the powerless and then
really the necessary connection
between the world of
science and the humanities.
So for the past 15 years,
spearheaded by our director,
Natalia Indrimi, Primo Levi Center
has, you know, has promoted the bait
around the work around Primo
Levi, and the broader history
of the Jewish precedence
in Italy really.
Many of our activities derived
directly from the questions
that Primo Levi raised, which led
to public programs and universities,
museums, and more recently,
the United Nations.
But what interests us
today is really the future,
how do we bring Primo
Levi to the 21st century.
Our answer is really through books.
So next to the Primo Levi's
own words, his complete works,
we started a small publishing
company, CPL Editions,
with a grown library titles, the
first 10 of which are available
for you to browser here later.
And it's been a privilege
to conceive a series
for the American audience from
whom the world of Primo Levi,
the world of Italian Jews, is really
something quite remote, even exotic.
So the goal of CPL Edition is
to create this wider context
for the work Primo
Levi, following his lead
in exploring the relationship
between history
and memory in our society.
I'd like to conclude with
saying that, you know,
when you talk about Primo
Levi's legacy, inevitably,
you're confronting with these large
words, large concepts of categories.
But what I would like to
leave you with a sense
of that Primo Levi
really brought all of this
down to a very personal issue.
He makes everything
extremely personal.
So far from moralizing
or ever being normative,
I think that Primo
Levi really teaches how
to ask poignant questions.
Thank you.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
Thank you, Alessandro.
[ Applause ]
So I would like to open
it up to questions.
There are microphones in the aisles,
and please come up
and ask a question.
>> OK.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
Go ahead, sir.
>> I just wanted to ask Anne
and Alessandro especially
about an impression I had from a
couple of different things I read
of Primo Levi and the movie "Truce".
And that is-- I just
found it very powerful.
I don't know what it
signifies to you, that when--
and I think about this in
terms of the suicide as well.
Or I guess it's controversial,
whether it's a suicide,
not a suicide.
That when he returns to
his apartment in Turin,
after all his experience, it
feels like nothing has changed
from the point of view of
the residence and so forth,
it's as if it was in
suspended animation.
And he comes back.
And from the point of view of the
people around him, you were gone,
you know, now you're back.
Is that a false impression
or is that no, doesn't mean.
>> Ann Goldstein: Well, yes.
I mean it was-- I think that
was sort of the root of his need
to recount what had happened to him.
That this was something-- I
mean, I guess you could say it--
put it that way, that it was--
everything else was the same
but of course it wasn't because
there haven't been a war.
I mean-- And everybody
had suffered in that war.
But I think that was certainly
coming back to Turin was, you know,
was part of the end to
this sort of normal life
or it wasn't really normal life.
>> Alessandro Cassin: I think most
importantly, he went back to--
in Italy, had been
devastated by the war.
It was not longer Jewish life
in Europe as they were before.
So the consequences
of this are gigantic.
The world that he came back
to really did not resemble
the Italy that he left.
I think that he went through, I
don't know, this transformation,
but what he found was a transformed
Italy, Turin and Europe really.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Adam Gopnic: Just to repeat to
everyone here the point being made
that is over there--
they've got a mic.
>> I mean he came to Italy.
He came back to a country that
had 20 years of dictatorship
that after the war had no
acknowledgements whatsoever,
we begin now.
In 1988, the racial laws were
acknowledged the Italian government.
>> Alessandro Cassin: Yes.
Italy had not the equivalent
of Nuremberg trials ever.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Yes sir.
>> Thank you for a
great presentation.
I have a question about
Primo Levi's children.
You don't really hear about them.
I was just wondering.
Maybe Ann Goldstein
would know about this.
What were-- What was
their involvement in this?
I get that he has a son and
daughter Renzo and Lisa, I think.
>> Ann Goldstein: Well, they
weren't really part of this project.
I mean they are there.
I mean they-- of course, without
them, I guess none of it can happen.
But we weren't directly
involved with them.
>> OK.
>> Ann Goldstein: OK.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Yes.
Hi, Lisa.
>> Hi. I was just wondering what
Primo Levi's reputation is in Italy.
Like how has the Italian's
society, culture, government kind
of viewed him over the
years because, of course,
I'm sure he's been critical
of those previous before.
>> Alessandro Cassin: Yes.
Well, it's a complicated story.
You know, they mentioned a bit
about the first edition of his work.
It took awhile for Italians
acknowledge Primo Levi is something
more than a witness of a show.
Eventually, this happened.
And I think the most significant
event in this process of recognizing
as major voice and
writer were two things.
One was that there were
school editions of his works,
his two first books
particularly, so that teachers
and students really
incorporate his work
in the curriculum of
the Italian schools.
The second major event was the
work of Marco Belpoliti a critique
who was the first person to really
highlight a literary valuable work
beyond the testimony.
So it took a long time.
It took a relatively long time.
But starting, it's really from
the late '50s, early '60s,
his reputation has grown steadily
and became very, very important now.
As I was mentioning
before, he also by writing
in the stamp of-- daily from Turin.
He became a major voice,
a moral compass.
So what happened would
be major events
from the nuclear disaster
[inaudible],
conflicts in the Middle East,
terrorist activity in the '70s
in Italy, people would turn
to him as a moral guide.
So in addition to his
literary reputation,
he really became a person to look--
>> Adam Gopnic: Yes,
I've often thought in a--
though in a slightly earlier period,
that his role must have been
very much like Albert Camus' role
in France in 1940s and 1960s.
>> Alessandro Cassin:
Yes, with differences.
But yes, those are very good--
>> Adam Gopnic: And both working
as journalists, as well as--
>> Alessandro Cassin: Right.
>> Adam Gopnic: --
working as [inaudible].
>> Michael Abramowitz: The
one thing that's fascinating
about this period is, of course,
is he was working fulltime as a--
>> Adam Gopnic: Chemist.
>> Ann Goldstein: Chemist.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
-- as a chemist.
>> Ann Goldstein: Right.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
That is at the business.
So his writing was done I guess
in the morning or at night.
So, over there.
>> The garden of the
[inaudible] about the plight
of Italian Jews under fascism.
I was thinking about the contrast
in Germany, though the [inaudible]
of anti-Semitism there, most German
Jewish intellectuals were profoundly
wedded to German culture of Garte
and Schiller [assumed
spelling] and so forth.
And I was wondering about Italy.
Do the Italian Jews generally
and specifically Primo Levi,
did they have that same attachment
to Italian culture and civilization?
>> Alessandro Cassin: Yes.
I would say absolutely yes.
Bassani [assumed spelling] as
Primo Levi were really anchored
to Italian literary tradition.
I think that if you read Levi's
carefully, you really Danta,
you find Manzuni, you find
a number of Italian writers
who influenced them
in a very major way.
And I think from the
unification of Italy,
Italians felt very loyal
to the Italian state.
And in this, they incorporated, you
know, Italian culture in general.
But yes. The question is yes.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Yes, ma'am.
>> This question is for Ann.
I've read both Primo Levi and
Elena Ferrante in Italian.
My Italian is not that good,
but I've struggled through it,
and then I read in your translation.
So I was wondering if you could talk
a little bit about the challenges
of translating because Primo
Levi uses a lot of Hebrew
or Yiddish terms, and then--
>> Ann Goldstein: No.
He doesn't.
I mean he doesn't use.
I mean Yiddish is sort of--
>> I guess in "Lilith" [assumed
spelling] anyway I read that--
>> Ann Goldstein: I'm sorry?
>> In "Lilith" he used--
it was the--
well, anyway, maybe you
could talk a little bit some
of the challenges of
translation and that.
>> Ann Goldstein: Well, I mean I
touched on some of them earlier.
But, yeah, I mean, Levi does
use a lot of scientific terms.
He also, another thing that he does,
is he uses a lot of unusual words.
He even makes up words.
So those are challenging.
And it's challenging, for example,
when he uses a scientific word
or an unusual word that
challenges to make it seem
as though the word is not that--
in English, it's not
just a bad translation,
but it's actually an unusual word.
So that's sort of a particular--
>> Adam Gopnic: Can I
ask you a question, Ann?
And in all the years
we've worked together,
I don't think I've ever asked.
And that is you become
the premier translator
of Italian into English with--
>> Ann Goldstein: Right.
>> Adam Gopnic: -- Ferrante
and Levi and many other things.
What made you fall in love?
You're not of Italian background--
>> Ann Goldstein: No.
>> Adam Gopnic: -- at all.
>> Ann Goldstein: Not at all.
>> Adam Gopnic: What made you fall
in love with the Italian language?
I think Dante.
I think I just-- I completely
fell in love Dante in,
I don't know, college or something.
And I was desperate to
read Dante in Italian.
And that was the beginning
of my love of Italian.
>> Michael Abramowitz:
So how old were you
when you started reading Italian
or start studying Italian?
>> Ann Goldstein: Well,
long after college.
I didn't learn Italian until I
was well into my 30's actually.
>> Adam Gopnic: This is
particularly asking-on question,
but it comes to mind.
And so-- But Italians
runs more fluent--
more fluidly from 14th century
to the present day
than English say would.
Because if you could read, you
know, if you're reading things in--
>> Ann Goldstein: Well, yeah.
I think-- Well, I don't know.
I mean, I-- my previous
languages were Latin and French
and I think was a great
basis for my Dante Italian.
And then, you know, I mean, I--
my studying of Italian was a little
bit irregular, so I don't really--
I'm not sure if I can really
even answer that question.
But yes, I didn't find it hard
to go from one to the next.
>> Michael Abramowitz: Yes, sir.
>> Do you think Levi
committed suicide
and if he did commit suicide
what should his readers think
about that act?
Was it just a personal
things of his or--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
I mean I think he did
commit suicide.
But I think that the
reasons are very complex.
They weren't-- It wasn't--
Was it Elie Wiesel who said--
>> Michael Abramowitz: Yes.
>> Ann Goldstein: -- Auschwitz
finally caught up with him.
I think that was--
>> Michael Abramowitz:
Forty years later.
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah, 40 years
later, I think that was sort
of a very superficial
reading of it--
>> Yes. This was a very-- also
opportunistic really but--
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah, but, well--
>> I think that I don't think
one can enter the mind of someone
who is abandon life
however we abandon it.
And I think that to read
retrospectively the work
and the commitment of an entire life
based on a step that can, you know,
can be made for-- and
can be taken on the--
in a moment for many different
reasons, that he was sick
or he was going through
a very difficult time,
I mean is really not something
fair to-- and is unfortunate,
something that many American
intellectuals beginning
with Wiesel have found
convenient to use.
And that's really not fair
thing especially in the face
of a lifetime work such as
the one that Levi left us.
>> Adam Gopnic: Might I add
something to that if I might?
That, you know, that it's certainly
a cheap caricature of Levi's life
and of his end to turn it
into Auschwitz caught
up with him finally.
You know, despaired.
In other words, his eloquent witness
was in someway ultimately false
because even Primo Levi--
>> Ann Goldstein: Right.
>> Adam Gopnic: --
took his own life.
That's clearly a parody
of his circumstance.
But in a broader sense, I do think
that the question of suicide,
why go on living is a central
one in European literature,
in Camus again and in Levi.
And so thinking about his biography,
in reverse, in a certain way,
that is, his persistence in
writing, in bearing witness,
in pursuing a life as a chemist,
as a writer, all of those things,
isn't cheapened by our
knowledge of his end.
I don't think we--
>> Ann Goldstein: No.
>> Of course--
>> Ann Goldstein: No, absolutely.
>> -- the work that takes a toll
and the work Primo Levi did.
>> Adam Gopnic: Yeah.
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Unveiling and revealing what
had happened in Italy, in Europe
and not taking the
position, "OK, I'm the victim,
those are the perpetrators,
and it'll never again."
He took the position saying,
we're all human beings--
>> Adam Gopnic: Right.
>> -- and anyone of us can nurture
and it bring to fruition those--
>> Adam Gopnic: He
walked a moral tightrope
for 40 years so that if he--
[ Multiple Speaker ]
>> And so he didn't
have anything to sell
that would be easily
circulatible [phonetic].
So it's a-- which was very
different from building--
>> Michael Abramowitz: OK.
>> Adam Gopnic: No uplift.
>> Michael Abramowitz: So I think we
have just a couple of more minutes.
I see two questions there.
Why don't you both ask the
question and then we'll wrap it up.
Go ahead.
>> My first question-- Well, my
only question, was do you believe
that Primo Levi wrote these books so
he could teach us a lesson of trying
to repeat our mistakes in the past?
>> Ann Goldstein:I don't think
Primo Levi would ever have thought
that he was teaching
anybody a lesson, but--
although he was very
interested in talking to--
in talking to children
and in visiting schools.
But I think that-- I
guess that's the lesson.
>> Levi wanted to understand how--
[ Multiple Speaker ]
>> Ann Goldstein: Yes.
>> -- society in which
we have certain rights
in freedoms can be
dismantled, this you wanted.
>> Did you have a question, sir?
>> If I may follow up on that
point, Primo Levi is a hero of mine,
kind of personal professional
mentor in this fashion.
He seems to be one of the few people
who have taken on, as you said,
that existential issue of
Europe ended at Auschwitz.
The civilization ended at Auschwitz,
that one full statement
you made earlier.
Given the Nazis' belief
that the Jews
and Judaism undermine the
natural race, conflict
and racial progression
that they believed in,
Primo Levi to me seems-- as a
person who really speaks to that
and challenges that in a deep way.
However, I'm not adequate to
really understand how he does
that effectively, he
does that for me.
Could you comment on that?
>> Adam Gopnic: If I'm--
What I would say about it is,
and it's something that
came up very clearly even
in the little film we saw a moment
ago and it's stomatic in all
of Levi's work is that
the pathogens of fascism,
what happened in his view
are sort of omnipresent.
These-- They're talking about them
being around in the '80s in Italy
and that his view is, is that,
we make a mistake if we see it
as a German aberration or
if we understand it as a--
one particular is of
one historical period
that we can escape and
look back on safely.
That we're forever in ways that
Americans should be thinking
about very hard at this moment,
that the pathogens of exclusion,
the pathogens of racism, the
pathogens of indifference,
pathogens of indifference
to what's going on around us
because we choose not to
see, it's actually threat
and it's actual consequences
that those are omnipresent
and permanent parts of
the human condition.
And ones that we ignore
at our enormous peril.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Abramowitz: Ann,
you want any final words?
>> Ann Goldstein: No, it's OK.
>> Michael Abramowitz: OK.
So thank you all for joining us.
Thank you the Primo Levi Center.
Thank you the Library of Congress.
I did want to say that Adam
is signing books at 2:30
and Ann is signing books at 1:30.
I don't think you require
to actually buy the book.
>> Adam Gopnic: You
should buy the book.
>> Ann Goldstein: Yeah.
>> Michael Abramowitz: But
thank you all for joining us.
>> Alessandro Cassin: If anybody
is interested, there are books
by Centro Primo Levi
here that you're free
to browse or ask questions about.
>> Adam Gopnic: Primo
Levi, "The Complete Works
of Primo Levi" are
a very good medicine
against the pathogens
we were describing.
>> Ann Goldstein: Yes.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.